[Music]
for now it remains unclear
what the future of the black panther
franchise will be but there's no doubt
chadwick's portrayal of king t'challa
has made a deep impact on our culture we
must
find a way to look after one another
i think seeing seeing little kids with
the black panther
mask and suit on it's amazing
the heartbreaking images say it all a
young boy with a tear running down his
cheek
kids holding memorials for black panther
with their action figures
the loss of their hero idol and role
model
cut deeply the kids it takes the cake
forever kids who see him in that black
panther role
and see a reflection of themselves
embodied in everything
that he intended you know they get to
dream about
and wish about black panther made more
than 1.3 billion dollars
but without two-time oscar winner denzel
washington paying it forward
chadwick's career could have taken a
different path i got a beneficiary
letter
and it said denzel washington paid for
you and i was like
uh i was like what and
just before the movie came out we did
the new york premiere he came and i met
him
and i said yeah i got to tell you
something you know you um pay for me to
go to school he said
oh oh so that's why i'm here you owe me
money
i like the movie black panther yeah
wakanda forever but
where's my money i want to be a great
king baba
has it soaked in what black panther
means to all these people
it's an amazing thing to think about um
to put myself in the shoes of a
of a kid now seeing it and happy that
they can take it for granted actually
chadwick kept his cancer battle a secret
from those he worked with
and managed to selflessly inspire lead
and give back to others
at the 2018 mtv movie awards he turned
the spotlight
onto another hero he fought off a gunman
in antioch tennessee at a waffle house
he saved lives come on up here
so this is gonna live at your house